okay what's up you guys i'm denny direct
oh i'm bryce sander and the drag race
all-star season 2 finale is upon us we
caught up with the queens themselves who
shared their favorite moments of the
season spoiler alert it's mostly fashion
of course flashback a year
oh god let's talk about your favorite
moment from the season I create a
product that is um not only very useful
but it's um really fun and I made a
commercial for it and I've always wanted
to do a commercial I want to sell stuff
I know what good booth look at my face
I've been burned by curling irons my
whole life and I keep coming back I'm
the ultimate customer and we got to talk
about Bjork Bjork you've always been out
there and I've always loved you and now
you know it and I'm happy hopefully we
we get a collab between the two of you
ah [ __ ] came on I like winning stuff so
it's been great to like win you're a
winner baby I won the snatch game that
was fabulous I got to be Mae West and
just like the fashion across the board
is just on a different level so it's
really fun to watch everybody come out
and just burn the runway every single
time I was surprised to see five season
five Queens a and then I was very
surprised with the twist I knew there
would be some kind of like little you
know trick Kitty trick just like when
you think you get over that hope you go
around the corner and there's another
wall but this one's six foot taller
[Music]
what favorite moment for you highlight
of this season the same parts which is
so awesome that that was so well
received and you blew it out of the
water first episode and then it's like
turned into a single that's on iTunes
and everything
boo third part and everyone's really
enjoying that version of it too so I
think that's probably like my a big
moment so far it's just that there's
only ten of us yeah everybody was so
phenomenal you're just competing with
the best so it's like you really have to
step your game up favorite look from the
season Roxxxy Andrews the the whole of
her over anything that Roxy does is
perfection to me that [ __ ] makes with
her own bare little grubby ask mother
[ __ ] hands the wig the makeup the lashes
the whole outfit top to bottom stitched
and steamed and ready to go she is the
walking pinnacle of drag
I love detoxes um rubber red pantsuit
from the past and the future detox with
latex it was just phenomenal
I loved Fifi's future of drag look that
whole Robo craziness I really loved
Katya's latex look seriously speaking my
best look has always been my backside no
it was the snatch game one with the
latex dressed by Nina Kay from the
Hollywood villains and it was so cool
because my friend Mallory and I designed
it and then me and Mallory and Nina
designed it it was a collaborative
effort I think my favorite fashion
moment is my t-boz inspired illusion I'm
a huge TLC fans that's gonna say we need
a TLC moment you're gonna bring it to us
my favorite look I'm gonna have to say
is probably everyone's least favorite
the camera dress
let's see that end up being your revenge
dress you came back flashing even Morial
it was just like I'm taking selfie to a
whole nother level the two and one the
two and one was so much fun and it was
creating it I never thought I'd be able
to pull it off but it did and it worked
out perfect I love my um blue with the
alien with the long claws the blue
little swimwear aqua looking thing
that runway especially for me is
something that I just love to do thank
you for watching guys let us know your
favorite part of the whole season below
also let us know what was your favorite
look of the entire season and be sure to
subscribe to e t--'s youtube channel